bonsoir je vais pas faire long vous
inquiétez pas il ya environ un mois
sonia m'a dit tu es censé durer combien
de temps une pause je me suis promis de
ne pas contacter sonia et puis
aujourd'hui j'ai craqué ça fait une rose
qu'elle a lu mon message est qu'il a
toujours pas répondu
pour ne rien arranger je suis coincé un
repas familial où la conversation qu'ont
actuellement autour et si surface au sol
et toi de rien on pense quoi vous me
demandez ce que je pense du chauffage au
sol alors j'ai envoyé un message à 17h24
et que j'ai toujours pas de réponse
foutez moi la paix merde
j'adorerais pouvoir répondre à un truc
comme ça je crois que ça ferait très
plaisir à ta soeur si tu faisais un
petit discours le jour de la cérémonie
oh [ __ ] je l'avais pas vu venir celle
là pourtant ça fait trois mois que je me
prépare au cauchemar de ce mariage
l'église le vin d'honneur et surtout la
chenille c'est une machine à broyer les
orgueils
si ça se trouve c'est la meilleure chose
qui puisse arriver ce discours pardon
mais ça c'est très bas marre de l'image
pour la toile dans cette famille arrêtez
de faire du vrai que c'est super
désagréable en fait ma musique est une
excellente école tackle ta gueule
tellement de choses à dire farmer pardon
des choses qu'on ne dit jamais parce
qu'on pense que c'est trop tard
et en fait je crois qu'il n'est jamais
trop tard
et c'est cadeau
c'est ce casse la gueule ça veut dire
qu'on passera ni de chiens sont ok